I would like to feel that my work has
impact in the world,
but I also need to approach this
question with a certain degree of
humility.
I mean,
we had Harvard sometimes think that
we're part of the greatest university in
the world,
but there are lots of other places now
that are also doing great things.
My work,
if I have influenced some people,
some people in leadership positions to
do things differently.
That's the important thing.
I do have many,
many people who read my books,
they quote me.
Um,
I'm sometimes recognized in airports,
but I also sit at meetings with world
leaders where I am convinced of my utter
irrelevance.
Um,
so I think that I have,
um,
had an impact in terms of the term
empowerment and the importance of
empowering people.
I think my work on change has guided
many,
many organizations,
not only through my books but through a
change tool kit on the worldwide web
that is being used by many companies and
governments around the world.
I think that the ideas have entered into
the vocabulary of leadership.
So much so that people sometimes forget
that.
I thought of it first and I guess that's
what's important because I'm going to go
on to the next idea.
Oh,
my proudest achievement is,
it's so hard to say.
My proudest achievement is generally the
most recent because of.
Because I had just put in so much effort
and so much struggle to do it.
I really work hard.
None of it comes easy.
So I think of my books as proud
achievements,
but I'm always proudest of the most
recent because I think that I've gone
further in whatever that is.
I'm certainly proud of my son of,
of being able to have a life
sufficiently balanced that I could have
a good family life and um,
and set forth my son upon the world.
I'm certainly proud of,
of the companies I've changed of the
ideas I've spawned and I could point to
particular ones of the presidential
campaigns that I've influenced of the
world leaders,
um,
with whom I've shared the stage and
numerous events who had already been
using my ideas,
but then go back and have learned
something that often shapes their
agenda.
I'm asked questions like,
well,
what should be the most important
priority for Columbia?
And I answer those questions,
so it's thought leadership,
it's working with the power of ideas and
it's wonderful that in this world of
giant enterprises,
ibm as 350,000 people and enormously
advanced technology and yet one person
whispering in the ear of a world leader
or an IBM executive can often change the
course of that company and sometimes the
course of history,
women in business
as well as women in leadership positions
in any sector have been something that
I've been very concerned about my entire
professional life.
And I have to say it was selfish because
I got my phd at a time when there were
very few people like me.
I was often the first of my kind sitting
in a room with people of another kind.
That's sometimes true by the way,
when I go as an American to the Middle
East now where I'm very different in
many respects.
So I was very concerned about,
um,
getting more women.
I thought it was in my self interest to
have my women colleagues first of all.
Then the whole image of women would
would have been elevated,
but also I wouldn't have had to sit
there and answer silly questions about
what's the women's point of view that I
wanted more at the table.
I also do care about opportunity and I
care about not breaking,
not being confined.
I care about,
I care about opportunity and I care
about not being trapped behind
stereotypes,
so now we've had the breakthroughs.
There's certainly more women in
leadership positions and lots and lots
of women in the pipeline.
What I'm concerned about now is that we
haven't changed institutions enough to
make it possible for women who want to
devote themselves to their children
during formative years to do that or for
men for that matter who say,
no,
I'd like to devote my time to my
children to do that.
Without feeling they sacrifice their
careers.
I think we still don't have enough women
in leadership to make it totally normal.
Or we wouldn't ask today's silly woman
question,
which is was carly Fiorina fired because
she was a woman?
And the answer is no.
She wasn't,
but all the attention she got afterwards
was because we had so few women ceos,
we didn't take it for granted,
but I think we have to get more women in
leadership.
In order to do that,
we need to help those talented women in
the pipeline feel that they can continue
to advance without sacrificing important
things to them in life.
They don't have to sacrifice their
career,
nor do they have to sacrifice their
family.
I think that more men ought to take on
some of those family responsibilities.
That was important to me.
I always felt there was a reason for two
parents and my husband did a great deal
and so we could lead more balanced
lives.
I think that to me is the frontier is
what we do about work and family work
life balance,
and if we crack that,
we will see all those talented women
taking on responsibilities and it will
look completely normal to have women do
important leadership tasks.